翻訳: Rieko Matsumoto
校正: Hiroko Kawano
誰もが住み続けたい街 誇りに思える街
それはどんな街だと思いますか?
そしてそんな街にするために 私達が
できることは どんなことだと思いますか？
私は五年前に 広報の専門職として
神戸市役所に入りました
神戸市役所の色んな部署に取材に行く中で
私が気付いたのは
この社会の中には 私が想像していた以上に
多種多様な課題が存在するということでした
例えば環境問題 子供の安全や子育て
防災や減災
人口減少社会 超高齢社会
こういった問題はとても根深く
そして複雑に絡み合いながら
私達の日常生活に深く影響しています
社会課題の解決は
そう簡単なことではありません
誰もが 「どこかで誰かが
なんとかしてくれてるんだろう」と
遠い世界のことのように考えがちです
実は私も市役所には入るまでは
そう考えていました
例えば 超高齢社会に関する課題
日本の高齢化比率は 急速に進んでいます
人口統計調査では 平成22年には
働く世代の人３人で１人のお年寄りを支える
という状況でした
それが平成37年には 働く世代の人２人で
１人のお年寄りを支える
という時代に突入すると言われています
こういう時代をいかに生き抜くか これは
私達みんなに突き付けられた課題です
大切なのは 見守り合う目を持つことです
認知症の初期には
同じことを何回も聞くとか
自分で電話番号を調べて
かけることができない
というような症状が現れます
このようなサインに早めに気付いて
お医者様に相談することで症状は改善されます
家族はもちろん 近所の人
いつもお買い物に行くお店の人が
「あれ？最近おじいちゃんの様子ちょっと
変だな」ということに気付いてあげることで
その人は少しでも長く自分らしい
暮らしをすることができるようになるのです
見守り合う目を持つことは
子供を虐待から守る上でも重要です
神戸市子供家庭センターが
対応するケースの中で一番多いのは
虐待者が実の両親であるということです
93％もの子供が実の親から
虐待を受けているのです
どんなにひどい虐待を受けても
子供は親との関係性を
絶たれたくない一心で
自分から他の人に訴えることはしません
保護されてからも
「自分が悪い子だったから」と
親をかばう子供が少なくないと言います
近所の人が
「夜中に独りでポツンと
公園にいる子供がいる」とか
「異様な泣き声が近くから聞こえる 」
こういったことに気付いて
通報することによって
虐待の連鎖は止められるかもしれません
このように 近隣の人たちが果たす役割は
大きく そして重要です
一人暮らしのおばあちゃんの異変や
子供の深刻な状況に
誰かが気付きそして
適切な行動を起こすことによって
その人達の未来は大きく変わるのです
私は行政広報の仕事をしながら
このような情報を発信し続けてきました
けれども 反応は驚くほど少なく
多くの人の関心を集めることは
とても困難なことでした
もちろん このような情報が
大切なことであるということは
ほとんどすべての人に
理解していただけると思います
助けあう社会ができれば良いに決まっている
みんなそう思っているはずです
けれども 実際の行動に結びつかない
それはなぜでしょうか？
「自分ごとにできない」というのが
その答えなのではないでしょうか？
現代社会は 無縁社会という言葉で
言い表わされるように
人と人との繋がりが希薄になって
「自分のプライベートに
入り込んで欲しくない」
「おせっかいだと思われたくない 」
と思うような人が増えてきています
また 「自分一人が何かをしたところで
社会が変わるわけはない」
という風に考える人もいるでしょう
でもそれでいいのでしょうか？
今は元気で順調に暮らしていても
ある日突然 誰かの助けが必要に
なることが あるかもしれません
そんな人が第一歩を踏み出すきっかけは
どこにあるのだろう？
それは「街を想う人を増やす」という
ごくシンプルなことではないのかな？
と私は考えました
神戸は20年前に
阪神淡路大震災を経験しました
震災の発生直後から 復興の
長い過程の中で
様々な社会課題が浮き彫りになりました
今まで経験したことのないような
状況の中で
みんなが生きるために 近所の人と繋がり
そして助け合うという状況になりました
震災発生直後に倒壊家屋の中に
閉じ込められた人を救ったのは
多くが近所の人
その割合は64％にも上ります
その後も 避難所で仮設住宅で
様々な地域で
多くの助け合いの活動が
生まれていきました
中には うまくいったことも
うまくいかなかったこともあったと思います
けれども 「大きな困難に出逢った時には
助け合う」 という気持ちが
神戸の人の心の中に刻み込まれたことは
間違いないと思います
そして今 神戸の中には
自分たちのアイデアで
街の課題を解決しようと
活動する人たちがいます
その活動のきっかけは
多くが震災なのです
震災から20年を機に 神戸市は
「BE KOBE 神戸は人の中にある」
というメッセージを発信しました
震災をきっかけに
様々な社会貢献活動をしてきた
75人の人のインタビューを掲載し
神戸の一番の魅力は
復興のために力を尽くしてきた
「人」なのだ と訴えたのです
紹介した人のプロフィールは様々です
被災体験を基に
防災訓練を行う地域のリーダー
震災の時に支援をしてもらったことが
きっかけで 今も被災地支援を続ける人達
こういった震災関連の
活動をする人はもちろんですが
地域みんなで子供を見守る
育てることを提唱する育メンや
外国人も暮らしやすい社会を創る
活動を行う地域活動家
商店街を中心に街の活気を創りだそうとする
お惣菜屋さん
こういった人たちも含まれます
中には 震災の時に何も考えなかった
ということをバネに
今では４万人の人を集めるチャリティー
イベントを開催する音楽プロデューサーや
東北の被災地にボランティアに行った時に
神戸の被災体験を聞かれて
何も答えられなかったこと[に]気づき
当時の聞き取り調査を始めた高校生
こういった人たちも含まれます
このような活動をする人達を
紹介することによって
自分たちの街にもこんな人がいるんだ
ということを知り
自分もこの街の一員なんだ
ということを誇りに思い
そして自分にも何かできることがある
と思う人が増えていくのではないか
と考えたのです
私達が発信した BE KOBEの想いが
集約された文章がありますので
ここで紹介したいと思います
「震災から20年
この歳月の中で
ひとつ はっきりしたことがあります
それは 「神戸の様々な魅力の中で
一番の魅力は人である」 ということ
この街には
街の復興のために力を尽くす人々がいます
困っている人に対して 当然のように手を差し
伸べる人が いまだに数えきれないほどいます
人は どれほどの困難に出逢っても
それでも前を向き 心を合わせて生きていく
大きな力を持っている
そのことを教えてくれた20年を
私達は大切にしたいと思います
それぞれの心の中で育まれてきた
それぞれの神戸
BE KOBEは
一人ひとりにそれを語ってもらい
みんなで共有し 歩みを進めるための
取り組みです
あなたもあなたの中の神戸と
今一度向き合ってください」
このメッセージには
発表直後から大きな反響が現れました
「これこそが神戸」
「この想いを自分たちの手で広めたい」
といった声を上げる人が
次々と現れ始めたのです
今からお見せする写真は
5月の2日から4日に
北野町のインフィオラータの会場で
撮影したものです
震災からの心の復興を願って始まった
花絵のイベント「インフィオラータ」
今年は街の人たちが BE KOBEをテーマ
にした 花絵を作って下さいました
会場の一角では
絵本画家のスズキコージさんが
子供たちと一緒に BE KOBEをテーマにした
巨大な塗り絵を描いて下さいました
スズキコージさんは
震災の後 神戸に移住して来られています
子供たちももちろん
震災を体験していません
この絵は
震災を経験した人も経験していない人も
共に神戸が経験したことを
前向きに 未来に伝えていこう
という想いで描かれた絵なのです
こういった楽しいイベントに
参加することからも
街への愛着や地域の繋がりは
生まれると思います
阪神淡路大震災は神戸の人にとっては
とても不幸な出来事でした
けれども いずれまた
そう[いう]災害は起こるであろうし
どこかで誰かが
直面しなければなりません
だからこそ私達は
あの経験をもう一度みんなで共有し
どう助け合っていくか？
どう立ち直っていくか？ということを考え
準備し続けなければなりません
そしてそうすることは
私達が今暮らしている社会の中に
山のように存在する社会課題を
解決することに繋がると思います
BE KOBEはまだ産まれたばかりです
この言葉が人々の心の中に染みこんで
いくのには 長い時間がかかると思います
そして人々の行動に結びつくのには 気の遠く
なるような時間がかかるのかもしれません
けれども 人々が「BE KOBE 」
「神戸であれ」と心の中でつぶやく時に
この街を誇りに思い 街のために
そして 自分以外の誰かのために
力を尽くす人でありたい
そう感じるのであれば
社会課題解決の第一歩になるものだと
私は信じています
方法は様々でも それぞれの人が
そんな第一歩を歩み出すことで
街の可能性は大きく拡がります
自分が住んでいる地域社会と繋がり
自分たちのアイデアで
暮らしやすい街を創っていく人達
誰かがやってくれるのを待つのではなく
自分自身が主体者となって
街に関わっていく人達
私達はBE KOBEを通じて
街を想う仲間を増やしていきたい
と思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）